all of joan crawford's footprints
oh my feet are smaller than joan
crawford's let me try
mine art hey
look my feet are smaller than gary
cooper's no kidding
mine aren't
and that is the gang from i love lucy at
what was and still is perhaps the most
famous movie palace in the world
grauman's chinese theater now known as
the tcl chinese theater has hosted
hundreds of film premieres and film
stars who left a unique token of
themselves behind as marcy gonzalez
tells us today that tradition celebrates
an anniversary
there are more memories of the titans of
tinsel town at the famous grauman's
chinese theater and every day rain or
shine thousands of movie fans come here
to walk where their idols have walked to
match footprints and fingerprints were
the joan crawfords
bing crosby's and marilyn monroe
it's a tradition that began by accident
exactly 95 years ago today on april 30th
1927. movie exhibitor sid grauman's
spectacular chinese theme theater was
yet to open the cement at the entrance
was freshly poured when silent film
stars norma talmage mary pickford and
douglas fairbanks came by for a tour
levi tinker is the tcl chinese theater's
resident historian sid gramma was
showing in the theater
norma talmidge accidentally stepped into
the wet cement sid grumman saw this
and as soon as he saw it right there on
the spot he had the idea this would be a
great way to not only celebrate the
movies and
but also promote the theater so on that
same day grauman asked all three actors
to put their footprints handprints and
autographs into the wet cement and the
four court of the stars was born the tcl
chinese theater was always going to be a
huge part of hollywood but when that
idea after seeing that footprint took
place
it
skyrocketed
over the years this small plot of land
has become a beloved time capsule a way
for movie fans to connect to all eras of
hollywood history and literally stand in
the footsteps of their favorite actors
stars from the golden age like shirley
temple clark gable and betty davis
giants from the 50s and 60s john wayne
sydney pottier and marilyn monroe and
stars of today including meryl streep
george clooney and denzel washington
each actor and filmmaker honored here
chosen by a committee in a very
selective process out of all the tens of
thousands of actors and actresses and
directors and producers only 334 have
ever placed their hands and feet in the
wet cement here so it's it's definitely
one of the bigger and harder
achievements to
achieve
about 5 million of those stars fans
visit this landmark each year yet even
with all that foot traffic the imprints
have held up thanks to a top secret
cement mixture those squares are
designed to last and it all comes down
to that recipe and
the cement artists themselves are the
ones who know what that recipe is and
with about 70 squares still open tinker
says there's space for this tradition
that's now inspired aspiring stars for
95 years to continue leaving fresh marks
in hollywood history for decades to come
for cbs saturday morning i'm marcie
gonzalez in hollywood
love that place i've been going there
since i was a kid because i'm such a
hollywood fan and film noir is such a
big plate on me but so glad to see that
the harry potter kids are there uh 2019
kevin hart right was the last to be
installed there darth vader but no
james earl jones you have c-3po you have
r2d2 there it's so interesting
why who gets in and why
and i remember going there the first
time and thinking one day i'll get my
oscar and yeah that's not good yeah but
that's all right the emmy the grammy
yeah sure yeah we'll we'll all be egos
there it is and they they still have 70
left spots 70 spots are still open so
we got it for the future